Speaker 1: Mypillow appears to be
going broke and CEO Mike Lindell,
known to us as Mike Pillow or just pillow, was on
the Steve Bannon program explaining what is going
on and that he has had to take out a $10 million
loan to stay afloat. Folks, I take no pleasure
in this. I really don't I don't take pleasure in
this. But actions have consequences. There can be
a reaction to the things you say and do, and it
can be bad for your business. Let's take a look
at this clip. Here is Mike Pillow revealing that
Pillow enterprises, my pillow is at significant
risk here. And just to keep things going and
make payroll, apparently with his 1500 employees,
he had to take out a loan. Look at this about.
Speaker 2: I guess, your loan, the loan you
took out at at Mypillow. People.
People are all over you about this.
Speaker 1: Did he say the loan
you took out at Mike Pillow?
Speaker 2: Yeah. Last year it actually
was three separate loans. And so as
the machine companies continue to sue us for.
Speaker 1: Oh, my God, he's blaming the machines.
Speaker 2: Billions of dollars. And we had to
borrow almost $10 million of my pillow. We're
a company. We're an employee owned company. I
just baffles me, Steve, you've got all these
companies. Are these machine companies out
there, these voting machine companies that
nobody even knew their name before, but everybody
protects them. And yet you attack a U.S. company,
my pillow and my employees, and it's just disgust.
Speaker 1: Yeah. So apparently he's taking his
anger out on the machine.
Speaker 2: We're doing a
class action lawsuit against all machines.
Speaker 1: So listen, I've interviewed Pillow
a couple of times, and the last time he was on,
I did ask him about the financial impact of this
tomfoolery. And he told me I've spent about
$35 million. So when he told me 35 million,
I think he was talking about in quote, these
words like, do words have meaning investigating,
quote, voter fraud as well as on lawyers and
traveling around and all of this different stuff.
He always had the choice to stop or never begin
this stuff in the first place. It is totally on
him and blaming others. Again, they espouse
personal responsibility and then they blame
others. In this case, he's blaming inanimate
objects. He's blaming the machines. The real
tragedy is that errors as a result of this
nonsense, his 1500 employees could end up out
of jobs. I'm not gloating here. It doesn't make me
happy. I don't want people to lose their jobs or
struggle to pay their bills. But this is the free
market that they admire and get on their knees
and pray at the altar of Don't let them trick you.
This had trouble written all over it when pillows
showed up at the White House. This was very early
in COVID. I guess it would have been 20 2020,
right? He showed up at the White House and said
Trump was a gift from God as president or whatever
it was that he said. Exactly. And we're going to
be making masks at some of our pillow factories
or whatever the promise was. By the way, did
they ever make the masks? I don't know. I never
heard about masks coming from Pillows factory.
And it's been down here. Ever since. So it's
not about woo hoo, 1500 people might lose their
jobs. It's about actions have consequences. And
apparently the combination of him spending
what a couple of months ago was already 35
million on this crusade to try to overturn an
election that doesn't need to be overturned,
combined with, I would guess, some deleterious
impact on sales as a result of the fact that he
has alienated at least half the country from
ever buying his products. And to be honest,
even some Republicans, I think now would say
I'm not. That's the crazy pillow guy with the
machines. I'm not buying that pillow. I'll get
a different pillow. How good could his pillow
really be? And people write to me and say it's not
actually that great. That is the impact. Those are
the repercussions of what he did. Everyone allowed
him to speak however he wanted, and his speech
included going on TV, making wild claims about
the election, hiring lawyers, getting cyber guys,
having his supposedly, as he would call it.
And now that had an impact. And other people
are speaking and the way that some businesses
have spoken, I forget which ones. But a bunch
of retail stores said we don't want the pillows
anymore. They spoke by saying we don't want to do
business with you anymore. Everybody gets to speak
to Beautiful Thing. And the speech that you choose
to engage in can have consequences to. Sad thing,
but it looks like my pillow may be going broke.